I I think they're wrong I think
democracy really is broken in this
country but what it's been broken by is
not the very legitimate criticisms about
the economic social consequences of
austerity and all that kind of thing
because they are part of the democratic
Radek process euro there is that that's
exactly what democracy is about
some people want austerity other people
want public services what it's been
broken by was the very fact of having a
referendum because and this this is
where I'd like to develop slightly Paris
quite the point is the point is that the
democracy in this country is a
representative parliamentary democracy
and has been throughout history are
actually almost every successful
democracy that has ever existed has been
a representative democracy rather than a
direct democracy and the reason for that
is that although the ultimate
sovereignty is vested in the people you
cannot and should not let the people
decide specific issues not because
they're incapable of it or they're too
stupid or too misinformed but because
each issue has to be decided in the
context of a whole lot of other issues
you can't ask people a simple yes/no
question and then hope to implement
and you know yeah
Europe and and the example the example I
always given I gave it here last night
so I'm sorry to repeat it is that if you
ask in a website or referendum you ask
people would you like to have more and
more gender than to more generous public
services overwhelmingly you'd have a
referendum saying yes if you ask people
would you like to pay lower taxes
overwhelmingly in a referendum you would
say yes well the answer to that could be
more government borrowing but if you ask
people in a referendum do you think we
should have more government borrowing
overwhelmingly every referendum would
say no and that's why you cannot decide
these issues that are not just complex
but interlocked and interconnected
through a direct democracy and that's
why we have Parliament now what has
happened is that the referendum and
unmark is right that Parliament took
this decision to turn it over to the
people and say that this is a once and
for all decision and that was the big
mistake that was the original sin and
you know it was David Cameron's however
I would just add one other point ok so
that original sin occurred people were
asked they did give a judgment by a
arguably decisive but small margin but
there are then those people who now
complain well that was not implemented
democracy has been broken because
Parliament gave a promise which they
have failed to implement that I think
has a completely false criticism
what has Parliament been doing for the
last three years if not a ferment a
referendum they have been doing nothing
else we have lost your we've had a
government which was totally committed
to implementing this referendum it had
it held a general election and then it
lost its majority but even after losing
majority it continued to be impressed
with implementing this referendum we've
now lost a prime minister as a result of
her determination to do nothing but
implement the results of the referendum
so after three years of Parliament and
government banging their heads against
this brick wall trying to implement a
reference
is it reasonable to go back to the
people and say well we've tried our
damnedest but we can't do it do you want
us to continue banging our heads against
a brick wall if the people want us to
happen fair enough David Davis himself
sent the final sent if a democracy can't
change its mind it ceases to be a
democracy Anatole
I think that's a really fine analysis of
what's happened and I want to back it up
with the the determination of the
Supreme Court because what the Supreme
Court did when it was considering the
role of parliament in triggering article
50 is it said that the referendum
decided that we should leave the EU but
it was for Parliament to decide how and
as you say parliament has desperately
been trying to decide how and has found
it incapable of coming up with a
satisfactory answer and if I can give
one apology to you and everybody else
it's that at some stage in the process
when we were debating having a
referendum I did not stand up in
Parliament and say this is insane to
decide the future of our country on
whether mrs. Jones at 52 acacia Avenue
happens to die on the 22nd of June or on
the 24th of June a 50% plus one
referendum cannot be the basis of our
country's future for the next 40 years
it should have been a threshold there
should have been a threshold that said
if you want to change the Constitution
it should be whatever it was 60% 66%
that meant it would be determined and
decided for in the next 20 30 40 years
and that would have been the way to do
it we didn't do it
that way that was a mistake and now we
have to move on from where we are for
more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you